think about it i feel like a lot of
the poker players you know ten tend
to be good at chess and they and they tend to
have uh followings that really feel like they
can win and we know he plays aggressive
stuff but i feel like sqc has has come so
far as we've seen from the first pog champs
and he is capable of of upsetting anybody
in the event we'll see how he deals with this
this wild danish gambit from negronio one two
three
four five he found the best move even if he may
not understand fully why it was needed to not move
the knight but push d5 instead as a counter attack
d5 is universally a very good way to strike back
because now black can just develop naturally
and and white doesn't have a development lead so
so xqc played this and now he's captured and
i don't think he's going to get in trouble at all
out of the opening especially if he gets castled
but i do it does emphasize that right now
is kind of a critical moment for negronio
okay and he does fine and he does cause a
king side this this can get very dangerous
for xqc he's up material but because of
the f file and this bishop pointing at f72
i i agree with you danny that if c6 um or even if
even if he doesn't push c6 i think daniel will be
oh what a good move by executing well this is this
is the best move everyone this develops the bishop
and inadvertently attacks the attacks the c4
bishop as well the knight is kind of pinned
because the queen and bishop are ganging up
here this is a very tough spot for white because
if white moves the knight he might lose the bishop
but if he doesn't xqc can trade and eliminate the
defender of the e3 pawn so look at how well he's
playing right now xqc is playing fantastic chess
what about my queen though pawn up wait a minute
again this is tricky this is tricky black does
have a few good options here but also really bad
ones because the position is suddenly very very
concrete like how he touches the queen so he can
see all the squares available one do what he says
yes yes yes bang it move boom
across bing bang bang think about it
yeah now what i have here is a multiple options i
can play this in many different ways that all work
oh yeah now you sweat he's sweating
he doesn't like this at all
my biggest worry now as an xqc fan is on the clock
it's true and time pressure has been getting to
him in the previous match he played as well so he
certainly needs to hurry up so that it will not
ruin a game where he has been playing brilliant
chess so far he has found the most critical most
precise moves d5 was extremely difficult bishop
to e6 just to alleviate that pressure over the
a2j diagonal he's playing the very best the
very most the very best the most critical moves
what was that see i'm just not seeing stuff
today that happens you know that happens
i'm not going to take my queen he's going
to take take f7 is under fire all right with
i think so too and then the d6 bishop is hanging
and again the f5 the f7 pawn and the king's safety
so let's see if first of all dania will take
it uh oh please queen h5 he didn't see that he
could take the bishop sometimes that happens
that's very strange when a trait happens that
you didn't see coming like your immediate sort of
emotional response is you know i'm losing i'm i'm
i'm on my heels right and and sometimes they
just miss that hey like you could just capture
back and i think that's the psychological risk
of being surprised but wow what what very short
you play and you pray
good motto from
daniel just resides big baby he has resigned
and we do have excuses celebration what a
game this has been grandmaster xqc
he played almost every single move
as the best move of the engine i feel like when it
came to that very complex opening and then i mean
he has he has come so far and that is a win
well deserved for xuc but he's gonna have to do
it again uh in in the next game to really secure
that man talk about a bracket that's up for grabs
right now right this group could be anybody's
anybody's win we're gonna take a very quick
break before they play their second game don't go
anywhere or pog champs three action and just a few
so the second game has just started with the
sicilian defense that's danielle's main opening
against e4 all right knight f6 played he's up a
minute and a half on the clock and this is not
the best spot for white in a sicilian to have
the queen in front of your minor pieces she's
much more comfortable kind of from behind here
where where she can support on the open files
and diagonals so this is this is a little bit
awkward for for xqc wait bing bang discovery
it's not a great idea here but it's
a great idea that he's seeing it
that's a thematic sacrifice in the
sicilian that i don't think he's
aware but he's looking at it as an option
very impressive that he spots those ideas
yeah seriously let's go with our initial plan
here original plan i think this is fine maybe
i'm wrong oh yeah i think that's good so you're
double attacking my knight is that gonna be a
problem i don't think so i think this c file
having that there i think is very valuable
up a pawn up a knight
the danger through the d fight excuse me
takes the knight you take back on e5 then
there could be a discovered attack
toward the queen bishop takes b5
first of all can we just get a moment of silence
for the fact that he used booyakasha that has not
been used since 1992. that's a that's a that's a
i mean boom goes the dynamite if we want to talk
cringe-worthy terms then i'm i speak fluent
cringe-worthy terms boo yakka shot can i get
noted thank you all right besides the bu yakasha
yeah i don't think he sees that if he takes here
he's losing to the discovered check um and uh
he's using the queen at the same time there's
so much material uh that's being given up that he
will have i think enough pieces for the queen but
yes this is very dangerous because of bishop takes
b5 oh my god and the rook is seeing the queen
let's go into xuc i think he sees it sacrifice
he just did it into queen take right oh my gosh
he doesn't realize he still has a lot of material
for the queen he does have a rook and two bishops
pair of bishops and the rook so he just needs to
make sure he finishes development places the king
in safety uh i wonder if xqc will spot queen takes
b5 and it's on the board okay negron you has to
see bishop c6 to save the day all right what are
you doing now you're taking my other bishop now
son of a all right holy the problem is if he
believes that he made a mistake he will not
see the opportunity that it was still okay
bishop c6 was still fine how about this
bang does that give me anywhere
at all a very strong move
i see it check oh he did i see it backwards
take back first take it is bang bang boom
sir sir listen we're going to
require you to make a legal move here
come on
could you please make an available legal
move the available legal move then let's take
got it i'm just shocked by the level of
play that xqc is showing in this match
um it was a very complex sicilian middle game
and he saw all those tactics with the discovered
attack toward the queen he's playing amazing chess
i mean honestly he's he's playing fantastic chess
this group is has me completely mind-boggled
you know i thought negrondi would be
the clear favorite after pokey's performance today
versus rubius and then watching xqc about to move
to i think if he wins this does he guarantee he
moves on to the championship bracket because he
already beat rubius so if he beats negron you we
might have a massive tie at the top of this thing
that's the thing he doesn't guarantee it because
pokey can beat xqc and then the three of them will
have the same amount of points yeah it could be
yeah and we'll look at it we'll look at it and
actually remind everybody of what the tiebreaker
is because the team was actually already they gave
me some info already about who has the best cap
score which is the tie break meaning who's playing
the most accurate chess the chess.com game report
gives you a cap score so that'll be what decides
if indeed we have three people tied at the top
but super hard for negron you to not lose his
cool there but no xqc gets all the credit in
the world again like he he's been looking at
the at the tactics you can see him highlighting
it and uh negron you did have a good position
but it fell apart and and like i said unless we
see a stalemate here i think uh i think we're we
know what we know what's about to happen so wow i
think excuse to learn the hard way throughout the
previous pog champs editions about the danger
of stalemate and he will not stop it again
you'd think so but sometimes those who get
stalemated stalemate others does that work i
don't even know well it doesn't matter because
negron you resign yes easy boys we're in it
next you see we got to start with you
this first game this danish gambit
you found this really critical idea of d5 take
us through did you know daniel was going to play
the danish gambit did he surprise you and what
were you thinking when you when you faced this
opening and you found this move d5 what is the
danish gambit is it for game one or game two
game one game one game one game so my thought
was only somebody that knows they're doing it
would let me get two pawns first spreading
a third pawn right so i thought i'm gonna
do something that isn't very good just to throw
them off because i knew something was going on
it worked out because the thing you thought
wasn't very good ends up being the best move
d5 is actually a really good idea for the future
so don't give it up and uh daniel were you what
were your thoughts when he played d5 and and
uh how well he handled your danish gambit
okay well first of all that's shocking okay
because the fact that he never heard it
everyone i play with at like 11 50 1200 reigning
when they don't know the danish gambit they never
play d5 because that's actually the one move that
really kind of sort of destroys the whole plan so
i thought he i was like okay he doesn't know the
danish gambit we're going to surprise him we're
going to win easy with white and he played it
really really well yeah and so none of my none of
the traps he fell into he just avoided everything
and then i was like my brain wasn't working this
morning still wasn't working while i played and
before i knew it i moved my knight into the wrong
spot um where i moved it to like an aggressive
position rather than like revert back yeah it was
safer um because i had another knight that was
protecting that uh h2 square that i just didn't
think about basically like you know blunder a a
knight or whatever so he had me on the ropes on
the first game i'm like that's okay we'll get him
with the sicilian on the next game no problem xqc
how early did you see this idea with the bishop
takes b5 check or did did you get kind of did
you kind of get lucky and it fell into your lap um
it's a half and half i i i had the root idea i had
another idea so i thought about um if if bishop
takes pawn takes queen takes then i have a cross
over between a queen takes rook and queen takes
pawn and then threatens rook right that's a very
good idea yeah so that was the main idea but then
then i uh once i i started looking at look at the
peace move i feel like when you see the piece move
and now you have the new board the new picture
it's easier to make a new idea because you
don't have to you know uh mentally make the
image the image is right there so then i thought
okay is there a check i could do to the king
that would yeah exactly we're doing on screening
yeah so now i was like okay is there a a check
that that the queen can't do anything about
that that my name that my rook takes queen
and then i've just found it so i was pretty
lucky from there but daniel i know this didn't
go the way you wanted to today but this group is
literally turning into the closest group every
match matters and and your play overall was
still really accurate and good just besides
those couple critical moments from each game so i
know you're frustrated but i know that this group
is still anyone's taking and so wishing you the
best of luck in the next match man yeah i think
you got that backwards because this group is
pretty much set okay because it's already set
like he's getting through i'm getting through
there's no they were both through right because
i have two wins oh wait no no because pokey pokey
is still has to play pokey can still win oh but
uh no no but no but but she's going against me
so no she can't oh okay right so what i'm saying
she's gonna do great you